The year is 1953.
The US purchases this
from Bell Labs...
the first commercial
silicon solar cell.
But these first solar cells
are not exactly efficient.
If you were to put them
on your roof
and try to generate electricity
it would cost you about
$300,000 a month.
Fast forward 70 years and
that cost has come down.
Way down.
Solar energy is the cheapest
it's ever been...
nearly 90% cheaper than it was
just in 2009.
In a lot of places
it is now cheaper to generate
electricity with solar...
than with coal, natural gas,
or nuclear power.
This is an unqualified
success story.
And if we can take the
right lessons from it...
this story can help us
create and deploy
all the other technology
we will need
to keep our planet livable.
They just became cheap
so quickly.
It's really an amazing breakthrough
that is going to come to define
the 21st century.
So how did solar energy go from
prohibitively expensive
to cheaper than fossil fuels?
“We're in an energy crisis now.”
In the 1970s, with
the oil crisis
there was a really big push
on research and development
for alternative energy.
“Today, in directly harnessing
the power of the sun
we're taking the energy that God gave us...
and using it to replace our dwindling
supplies of fossil fuels.”
With Project Independece,
as it was called...
the US federal government
allotted more than $8 billion
to solar research and development.
That really made a huge difference
and probably doubled
the efficiency of the cells.
It was a guy named Paul Maycock
who came from Texas Instruments.
—Oh, like the calculators?
—Yeah!
Working on calculators,
and he found for calculators...
the more they built, the cheaper
the calculators got.
And he said, same thing
for solar.
If we build more, the cost
will come down.
But before the US could really test
Maycock’s idea
President Reagan canceled
Project Independence.
Fortunately, two countries
were ready to step in
and put Maycock’s hypothesis
to the test.
Like the US, Japan
had been hit hard
by the oil crisis in the 70s.
They started funding solar
research and development
around the same time
and soon they developed solar cells
small and powerful enough
to run watches, calculators,
and toys.
Trivial, in terms of the
global energy system...
but crucial in that large companies
were now becoming interested
in solar and crucially, figuring out
how to construct solar...
at really low, low cost.
That knowhow came in handy when
the Japanese government
announced a major subsidy for
rooftop solar in the mid-90s.
But the global market for
solar technology
was still relatively small.
Until Germany stepped in and
truly changed the game.
The most important policy
on this whole chain,
if I had to pick one
it would be the German feed-in tariff.
Feed-in tarriffs.
Which was basically a program
that deployed solar at scale.
Here's how it worked.
Starting in 2000, the
German government
basically said to power companies...
Hey, if you can start producing
renewable energy
we will buy it from you.
We promise for double the market price
and we will keep paying you at that rate
for the next 20 years.
And so for developers of solar projects
in Germany, all of a sudden...
it became like a no-brainer
to do this.
Even though Germany is not
the sunniest place in the world.
Companies responded to
the incentives by building
solar farms like this one.
In one year, the installations for solar
went up by a factor of 4
and then it just grew.
The more panels they produced,
the cheaper it got
to generate electricity with solar.
Then another country
picked up the baton...
and made solar cheaper than even
Maycock could have imagined.
So it really starts with
Deng Xiaoping in the 1980s
and had this plan for a thousand
Chinese students to go abroad
and come back and see what
they came back with.
One group of students went to
the University of New South Wales
in Australia, where they
worked with a team
that was producing some of
the most efficient
solar cells in the world.
After a few years, one of those students
went back to China...
and opened up the country's first
commercial solar manufacturer
Suntech in 2002.
With that new German law in place
the company had so much success
selling solar panels to Germany...
Suntech success attracted competitors...
which helped drive down prices
in part because all of this demand
inspired Chinese manufacturers
to produce at an unprecedented scale.
Policymakers around the world
noticed the falling prices and wrote laws
to create new markets
in their countries, including
the United States.
The United States passed
an important law.
It's called the Energy Policy Act 2005.
And buried deep within that law
was an investment tax credit.
Sounds kind of boring,
but it turns out
it was absolutely critical
to deploying solar...
because what it said was that
if you put out a new solar project...
you can get 30% of those costs
back for a tax credit.
This sparked a phenomenon
called solar leasing...
where companies would look
for places to put solar
so that they could reduce the amount
they owed the federal government in taxes.
Other policies helped create
markets for solar modules
in Spain, Italy and crucially,
in China.
The Chinese devised their own
subsidy program
that was modeled on the German one
where you get a guaranteed price.
By 2011, China was not only
the biggest producer of solar...
but the biggest producer of solar electricity.
In the course of a single lifetime
solar energy has transformed
from a niche technology
to the cheapest way to bring
clean, reliable power
to billions of people around the world.
But the markets that brought us
these lower prices
didn't just magically appear
by some invisible hand.
Political leaders in countries
all over the world
created these markets,
then subsidized them
for decades to the tune
of billions of dollars.
By investing that money
you got the solar to
come down in costs
to the point where you don't need
to subsidize it anymore.
We're doing that on purpose
with things like batteries
and electric vehicles.
We're doing that with things
like heat pumps.
Solar provided us with
a playbook
for how to do that for
other technologies.